Let's get scale. Let's get scales up
here. Scales, how you doing? Hello.
Hello. Can you hear me? Yes. Yes, we
hear you. You're a Muslim. Yes. All
right. So, what you think about the
Islamic dilemma? I think that it's been
long debunked. You think it's been
debunked? Okay. Give us your best
debunking. Yeah. What? How do you debunk
it? Well, I'd like to hear you define it
first. I know you've done that a little
bit, but maybe just like a brief
summary. Quran confirms previous
scriptures. Quran contradicts previous
scriptures. So Quran is false because
previous scriptures are true. If
previous scriptures are corrupted then
Quran is still false for saying
corrupted books are true. All right. So
I don't believe that the Quran is saying
that corrupted books are true. When it
says about the previous books like
confirming that it's talking about the
message the primary message that there
is one God that to worship him. You've
been here before. Uh, yeah. We haven't
talked about this subject. No. Oh. What
did we talk about last time? Do you
remember? Uh, I don't remember. Okay.
All right. Go ahead, though. Do you do
you mind if I call you by your name or
do you want me to just call you Scales?
Uh, you can call me Scales. All right.
Um, but yeah, like confirming that which
is before um is not necessarily like a
letterby
confirmation. It's uh it says confirming
what's with them. Yeah. the Torah and
the or I guess I should say the remnants
of the Torah and the Gospel are with
them. It doesn't say that. It says
confirming what is with them, not
confirming the remnants that's with you.
So, it's not going to go and give the
full a toz argument every time that it
mentions it. There are other sections of
the Quran that mention that they change
the words in the Torah with their hands
where in al Bakar. Yeah. Show show us
where it says that they changed the
Torah with their hands. Now remember
what you specifically said and what I'm
specifically asking for that they
changed the Torah with their hands. So
there's verse 285 and sorts of bakaroo.
285. Go ahead and read that. That's one
of our favorite verses. What does 285
say? Uh you want it in English? Yeah,
please. Okay. Let me let me pull up a
translation then. Give me one second
here. All right. 285
285 So it says then those then you are
those the same ones who are killing one
another and evicting a party of your
people from their homes. It's talking
about the Jews here cooperating against
them in sin and aggression. And if they
come to you as captives, you ransom them
although their eviction was forbidden to
you. So do you believe in part of the
scripture and disbelieve in part? What?
Sorry. This is the this is the not the
one about where they change it but yeah
it's about the disbelieving and
believing in part. So according to this
verse wait just just go ahead and finish
it. Yeah. Yeah. So do you believe in
part of the scripture and disbelieve in
part? Then what is the recompense for
those who do that among you except
disgrace in worldly life and on the day
of resurrection they will be sent to the
severest of punishment and Allah is not
unaware of what you do. Wait a second.
You mean to tell me John? Did y'all hear
that right? You heard it. So Allah hates
when people pick and choose in his
scriptures what they choose to believe
and disbelieve.
That's what it says. And then if they
pick and choose if they say like for
example there's remnants of the of it.
That's true. Oh, I'm not telling them to
believe in the remnants. I'm telling
them to believe in the Quran. But what
about that? You're saying you're saying
that the the Torah and the Gospel they
have is partially true. Sure. But the
Quran says you can't do that. You can't
have you can't believe in part of it.
You got to believe in all of it or else
you're going to h going to hell. So it
says, do you believe in part of the
scripture and disbelieve in part? So you
cannot believe in part of a scripture
and disbelieve in another part. So
therefore, no. I'm believing in the
entire Quran. No. Are you believing in
the Are you believing in the in the
whole Torah? No. Okay. You're believing
in part of the Tora. Oh, I don't believe
in any part of the Torah. I just happen
to similarities and in the what we have
today? No. Okay. Didn't you say that
parts of it are true? Parts of it are in
alignment of the Quran. So, they're
necessarily true. If a kid writes a
children's book and says that God is
one, part of that story is true. You
mean that I believe in the story? So,
you affirm parts of it and reject other
parts. Yes. again like with the example
of the story. I can write a story today
and I can say God is one. Part of that
story is true and another part is not
you're not helping your case. That's not
what I'm trying to believe. I'm not
saying hey Christians, hey Jews, believe
in part of your book.
Did they have the Torah with them? They
had the altered Torah.
So they had the Torah with them that was
partially true. Again, you're doing this
like false equivalence kind of thing.
actually true and believing in a
different part are two completely
different things. Look, let's let's do
this very clearly and slowly. Sure. They
had the Torah with them, right? I
wouldn't call it the Torah cuz it's
corrupted. But the Quran calls it the
Torah, though. No, it's a scripture. Go
to Go to 757.
757. Okay. So, you're going to learn
your Quran today for sure. Today going
to be the day, man. Yeah. Okay. What's
the thing around here, y'all? So read
and mention when we raised the mountain
above them as if it were a dark cloud.
Seven seven brother 7 157. Oh 157. Okay.
157. Okay. Those who follow the
messenger, the unlettered prophet, whom
they find written in what they have of
the Torah and the gospel, who enjoin
upon them what is right and prohibits
them from what is wrong and makes lawful
for them what is good and them from what
is evil and re relieves them. It's
okay, brother. The rest of the verse is
irrelevant. It's it's I will complete
the verse. uh and the shackles which
were upon them. So who so they who have
believed in him, honored him, supported
him, and followed the light which was
sent down with them. It is those who
will be successful. Trying to buy time,
bro. Problem with this. Okay. You see
how it says that they have the Torah.
What they have of the Torah. No, it
doesn't say I'm sorry. It doesn't say
what they have of the Torah. Matter of
fact, that's even a horrible
translation. You know the Arabic, right?
Yeah. Can you can you read that part in
Arabic? Let's see.
Yeah. Does it say from where does it
say? Does it
say all of the
It says what does mean? It means in the
Torah and the Thank you. Not parts of it
or it not from it. In in it. In it. The
whole of it. And they have it with them.
Right. Right. They have Okay. I guess uh
I'll correct myself. You you have a fair
point there. Thank you. The Quran refers
to what they have as the Torah in the
Gospel. Although it is corrupted, but it
is referred to as the Torah and the
Gospel. Wait, wait. Not yet, Deos. Not
yet. It never says corrupted. Let's have
some fun here. Okay. Yeah, you have the
fun. You have the fun. So, we have that
we we see that they have the Torah and
they have the gospel. We got that part
out of the way. Now, now you're saying
that what the Torah that they have is
partially true. Correct? It has truths
in it. And it is it full brother. My
question is very simple. Is the Torah
that they have is it completely true or
is it partially true? It is not
completely true. So it is partially
true, right? It has truths in it. So it
is partially true, right? Sure. Thank
you. So you are believing in part of the
book while rejecting other parts.
Correct. No, I'll tell you again in the
children's book. If the children says
Allah is one, appreciate, right? I'm not
rejecting that book and believing in
part. You could say that about go and
watch your head on the way out. Yeah,
man. I want to know where does the Quran
talk about this children's books he keep
talking about. And where does it say
parts except to say that you shouldn't
believe in some parts? So apparently
Allah revealed a children's book. All
right. I mean, what's this? What are
Muslims doing? So, so now now the Torah
in the angel has a coloring book. One of
Aisha's coloring books. That's crazy.
No, that's like so disrespectful to
Allah to say that about his books. Oh my
gosh. Yep. Guys, this is what happens.
See, we can give them verbatim what
we're saying, right guys? Oh yeah. What
we say what we're saying is not implied.
It's not
suggested. It's not hinted at. It's
verbatim in there. You can't believe in
part of the book. What they have is the
Torah and the Gospel and it's with them
verbatim. But then they come out and
say, "Oh, well, you know, some of it is
good. Uh there's remnants of it or it's
not really with them. Show us that."
They can't show us a single thing that
says what they say. Nothing. Not Not
even hinting at it. Exactly. You know
what the real Do you know what the real
children's book in this scenario is?
their dais script that keep says
corrupted remnants corrupted partial
this this that's the real children's
book that has not a lot of truth in